guys i really thought we might struggle
at quarterback but it turns out you're
both better than the corpse of big ben
that we threw out there last year yeah
why'd you stick with him for so long at
the end of his career he looked like an
obese grandma with cement cleats i know
but it was either him or mason rudolph
and mason's face just annoys me yeah
that's fair with that said though we do
have to name a start well coach if you
want a veteran who will get the job done
i'm your guy and if you want someone
that actually has some upside i'm your
guy hey you've been playing really well
this preseason are you sure you've been
using a regulation ball because i've
seen those tiny hands your girl has no
problem with the size of my hands i'm
more accomplished than you your biggest
accomplishment is from a game that aired
on nickelodeon congratulations a bunch
of ten-year-olds took a break from
playing fortnite and picking their nose
to vote for you whatever coach who's
gonna be the starter oh it's not my
choice what whose choice is it his we're
all afraid of him so we're just letting
him choose to choose mitch why your last
name's too similar to mine i don't like
that yes let's go i don't know why
you're so excited why wouldn't i be have
you seen your offensive line are those
wet paper towels yeah you might be in
the hospital by week two